♪ ♪
>> Sean: TONIGHT ONE OF
AMERICA'S NEWEST RESIDENCE
PRINCE HARRY IS ONCE AGAIN
BASHING THE USA, USING A
RECENT SPEECH AT THE U.N. TO SAY
THIS ABOUT OUR GREAT COUNTRY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
TO SPEAK OF THIS HAS BEEN A
PAINFUL YEAR IN A PAINFUL
DECADE.
WE ARE LIVING THROUGH A PANDEMIC
THAT CONTINUES TO RAVAGE
COMMUNITIES IN EVERY CORNER OF
THE GLOBE.
CLIMATE CHANGE AND WREAKING
HAVOC ON OUR PLANET, WITH THE
MOST VULNERABLE SUFFERING MOST
OF ALL.
THE FEW WEAPONIZING LIES AND
DISINFORMATION AT THE EXPENSE OF
THE MANY AND FROM THE HORRIFIC
WAR IN UKRAINE TO THE ROLLING
BACK OF CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES, WE
ARE WITNESSING A GLOBAL ASSAULT
ON DEMOCRACY AND FREEDOM.
>> Sean: SAVE US THE LECTURES.
THOSE CONDESCENDING REMARKS
PROMPTED WIDESPREAD MOCKERY FOR
HARRY'S COMPLETE AND TOTAL
DISCONNECT FROM REALITY.
REMEMBER HE AND ALONG WITH HIS E
MEGHAN MARKLE ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO CLAIM THEY WANT TO
PRIVACY, SO WHILE THE HATRED AND
DISDAIN FOR THE COUNTRY THAT HE
IS CHOOSING TO MOVE TO AFTER
REJECTING ROYAL LIFE IN THE U.K.
BUT HE IS STILL A MULTI,
MULTIMILLIONAIRE.
WHY ALL THE ANIMOSITY AND HATRED
AND ANGER FROM SOMEONE THAT
LIVES SUCH A PRIVILEGED LIFE
CUSTOMER CARE TO ANSWER THAT IS
SO MUCH MORE, I CAN'T THINK OF A
BETTER GUEST FOR THIS, HOST OF
"UNCENSORED" FOX NATION HOST
PIERS MORGAN.
I'M A LITTLE BIT SICK AND TIRED
OF THIS PUTRID WOKE RHETORIC
LECTURING FROM MEGHAN MARKLE AND
HARRY.
THEY CLAIM THEY WANT PRIVACY BUT
THEN THEY GO ON OPRAH FOR THE
BIG OPRAH INTERVIEW, THEN THEY
ARE DOING A TV SERIES, NOW THEY
ARE WRITING ABOUT, NOW THEY ARE
GOING AND BLASTING THE U.S. AT
THE U.N.
YOU KNOW WELL, I DON'T CARE WHAT
HAIRY THINGS AND I DON'T CARE
WHAT MEGHAN MARKLE DO ALL MY
THINGS AND IF THEY DON'T LIKE IT
HERE, YOU CAN HAVE THEM BACK.
I WILL PAY FOR THEIR PRIVATE JET
BACK.
HE SPAKE A LET'S NOT BE TOO
HASTY, WE JUST GOT RID OF THEM.
THIS IS THE ONLY BENEFIT ALL OF
THIS.
>> Sean: THANKS A LOT, YOU'RE
REALLY ABOUT.
THANKS A LOT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS, IT IS
REVENGE I'M AFRAID.
WE WAITED A LONG TIME.
YOU SENT WALLIS SIMPSON OVER TO
DESTROY OUR MONARCHY, WE HAVE
SENT HARRY TO GOING TO RUIN YOUR
LIVES.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
ONE FOR ONE.
TO BE SERIOUS, IT IS SUCH A
SHOCKING HYPOCRISY ABOUT
PRINCE HARRY AND HIS WIFE MEGHAN
ON THE WAY THEY GO ABOUT THIS.
THEY ARE LITERALLY LECTURING US
AGAIN ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HOW DID HE GET TO NEW YORK TO
MAKE HIS SPEECH?
PRIVATE JET.
HOW DO THEY ALWAYS TRAVEL?
IF GOT A PROBLEM WITH PRIVATE
JETS BUT STOPPED BANGING ON,
LECTURING THE REST OF US ABOUT
HOW TO SAVE OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT
WHEN YOU HAVE NO DESIRE TO DO
THAT YOURSELVES.
HE WAS SPEAKING ON
NELSON MANDELA DAY.
CAN YOU THINK OF ANYBODY LESS
QUALIFIED TO TALK ABOUT A
STRUGGLE OF NELSON MANDELA'S
KIND THAN PRINCE HARRY, WHOSE
OWN SENSE OF FREEDOM, THIS BOOK
CALLED FINDING FREEDOM,
NELSON MANDELA'S LONG WALK TO
FREEDOM.
MANDELA LIVED IN A SIX BY SIX
PRISON CELL FOR 27 YEARS AS A
PRISONER AND THEN CAME OUT AND
BECAME ONE OF THE GREATEST, MOST
ICONIC FIGURES OF MY ENTIRE
LIFETIME.
PRINCE HARRY DITCHED HIS FAMILY,
HE DITCHED HIS COUNTRY, HE
DITCHED EVERYTHING THAT HE STOOD
FOR, HE DITCHED MOST OF HIS
FRIENDS AND HE FLED THE U.K. TO
GO LIVE IN CALIFORNIA WITH HIS
SPOILED, WOKE WIFE AND AN
$11 MILLION MANSION FOR WHICH
THEY PREACH ABOUT EQUALITY AND .
YOU COULDN'T MAKE IT UP, IT IS
COMPLETELY RIDICULOUS AND I
THINK HE'S GOT TO BE VERY
CAREFUL NOW.
IF HE IS A RENEGADE ROYAL NOT
DOING ANY OFFICIAL DUTY BUT JUST
HAVING HIS ROYAL CAKE AND EAT IT
AND HE STARTS TRASHING THE
AMERICAN CONSTITUTION AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE WAY HE IS
NOW DOING AND THE SAME WAY THAT
HE AND HIS WIFE TRASH TO THE
ROYAL FAMILY, IS NOT GOING TO
END WELL.
>>